Transcriber: Leslie Gauthier
I’m a bald man --
(Laughter)
but I don’t miss my hair.
What I do miss
is going to the hairdresser.
I found it to be such an enjoyable
and relaxing experience.
I loved it when they would
rub their fingers through my hair
while they washed
my hair in the sink.
I enjoyed it when
they walked me over to the chair,
and they would play with my hair more
and talk to me about different hairstyles
and haircuts I could get.
And I even enjoyed
the gentle sound of the scissors --
snip, snip, snip --
right next to my ears.
I enjoyed it so much
and I was so deeply relaxed
that I remember many times
I would just sit there
and I’d think, “I’d pay you even
if you just pretended to cut my hair.”
(Laughter)
There’s another moment also
that often stimulates
this deep relaxation for me.
It’s whenever I get an eye exam.
(Laughing)
And I’m not talking about those puffs
of air they blow into your eyeballs.
That just makes my eyelids flutter
thinking about it.
But instead it’s when
they bring out the wheels of lenses.
(Laughter)
And they click through them all.
And they want to know
which lens helps you see better.
“One or two?”
(Laughter)
And they say it
in this very relaxing voice.
(Laughter)
And there’s something about
that moment of personal attention
and that soft voice
that just deeply relaxes me.
And it gives me these light,
sparkling, pleasurable brain tingles.
I enjoy it so much
that as they click through each option,
I want it to last a little bit longer.
So when they ask me, “One or two?”
I say, “Oh, I’m not sure.”
(Laughter)
Another moment that often stimulates
this deep form of relaxation
is when I watch the TV show,
Bob Ross’s “Joy of Painting.”
(Laughter and applause)
I would come home from school,
throw some pillows on the floor,
lie down
and let that soft voice
just sweep over me.
And he had the nicest personality.
He’d turn to the camera,
he’d look right at me,
and he’d say the kindest things
like,  “There are no mistakes,
just happy accidents.”
(Laughter)
And then he’d turn back to his canvas
and he’d make these gentle,
relaxing sounds with his paintbrush.
Tap, tap ...
tap, tap, tap.
And I found it so relaxing
that I often fell asleep
and never saw him finish the painting.
(Laughter)
In 2013, I learned that this special
response has a special name.
Autonomous Sensory Meridian Response,
or much more simply, ASMR.
That is a complicated word,
so it’s a good thing
we’ve got it simplified.
Now, I’m a physiologist.
I’m a researcher.
I’m a data nerd.
I was so excited to read
about the science of ASMR.
In 2013, there wasn’t a single
peer-reviewed research study.
What I did find were plenty of forums:
thousands and thousands of comments,
all across the internet,
discussing this blissful sensation.
And they all reported
the same response that I felt.
They were deeply relaxed,
they felt comforted,
they felt calmed
and they had these light,
sparkly brain tingles.
And I also noticed
that every scenario they described
that stimulated their ASMR
had a simple theme to it.
It was always when they were receiving
positive personal attention
from a kind and caring individual.
And the examples they gave
were very similar to my moments.
It was moments with hairdressers;
it was moments
with health care professionals;
it was moments with teachers.
They’d tell stories of the teacher
from their childhood with the soft voice
who would kneel down next to them
and help them solve a math problem.
It was moments with parents.
It was moments with their best friends
when they would whisper
to each other in childhood.
Or they’d braid each other’s hair.
Or they’d play that game
where you just lightly with your finger
draw letters on each other’s backs
and try to guess the letter.
But the moment that stimulated ASMR
that I saw the most often mentioned
was watching the TV show,
Bob Ross’s “Joy of Painting.”
(Laughter)
Now we know Bob Ross was not
trying to stimulate people’s ASMR
or cause them to relax.
He was trying to teach you how to paint.
But there are individuals today
who are creating ASMR videos
just for the purpose
of relaxing their viewers
and helping them
to fall asleep more easily.
They’re called ASMR artists,
and they have millions of followers.
Some of them have more followers
to their YouTube channel
than Kim Kardashian has
to her YouTuve channel.
And what are they doing in these videos?
Well very simply,
they’re sitting close to the camera,
they’re gazing into the lens,
and they’re speaking softly
or they're whispering gently.
They may even be pretending
to be a hairdresser
or pretending to be
a health care professional
or just speaking softly
the way a close friend would to you.
And right now ...
I’d like to introduce you
to some very popular
ASMR artists on YouTube.
So lean back,
stretch out your legs.
(Laughter)
And enjoy.
(Video) ASMR Glow: Good.
Good.
One last time.
Great.
(Video) WhispersRed ASMR: So there
are lots of different things we need.
Some we would have
in our regular spa kit.
Some of them are quite obvious.
(Breathing)
Things like ...
cotton buds ...
and ...
cotton pads.
(Video) Paris ASMR: I’ve brought
some tasty tea from Paris.
For you, yeah.
It is called, “Weekend à Paris.”
“Weekend in Paris.”
I think it takes like, um ...
um, rose.
(Video) Gentle Whispering ASMR: Alright.
A bit to the front here.
(Scissors cut)
OK.
Stay still.
(Scissors cut)
Stay to make sure ...
It’s nice and even.
Mhm.
Craig Richard: Now,
if you felt deeply relaxed
or maybe you felt
those special brain tingles,
you might have been wondering,
“What is going on inside my brain?”
Well, we wondered the same thing.
I recently published
a brain scan study with Bryson Lochte
and other researchers
from Dartmouth College.
And we saw that the brain regions
that are activated
while people are watching
ASMR videos like these
are the same brain regions
that are activated
when people are receiving
positive personal attention
from a kind and caring person
in the real world.
I’ve also collected data
from over 30,000 participants
as part of a research study
with Karissa Burnett and Jennifer Allen.
And Jennifer Allen is the woman
who coined the term
Autonomous Sensory
Meridian Response in 2010.
And what we see
is that ASMR is experienced
in over 130 different countries.
And the people are reporting
the same experience.
They feel deeply relaxed.
They have these special,
light brain tingles.
And it’s helping them
to fall asleep more easily,
and it’s helping them
to reduce their stress.
Even individuals who are diagnosed
with anxiety and insomnia
are reporting benefits
from watching these ASMR videos
and experiencing ASMR.
Other institutions
are also publishing data about ASMR
and they’re reporting
similar health benefits.
One study in particular,
from the University of Sheffield
in the United Kingdom,
showed that when people watch ASMR videos,
their heart rates significantly
and effectively are reduced.
Now there’s plenty
of unanswered questions still.
Like, what might be the brain chemicals
that are causing this amazing sensation?
One likely candidate
is the neural hormone oxytocin,
and you might have heard
of this as “the love hormone.”
It’s already well known
that your oxytocin levels
in your brain increase
when anyone gives you
positive personal attention
in a kind and caring way.
It's also already known that your oxytocin
levels, when they increase,
you’ll feel relaxed,
you’ll feel calmed,
you’ll feel comforted.
Another big question is why doesn’t
everyone experience ASMR?
You might have been watching
those video clips and been like,
“I didn’t feel any of those
amazing brain tingles.
Grrr!”
(Laughter)
Well, it could be that those clips
aren’t the ones that work for you.
If you've never felt this experience,
maybe you just haven’t had
the right real-world encounter yet.
Or maybe it's determined at birth.
It could be determined by the sequence
of your genes related to oxytocin
or other brain chemicals.
Another big question is how
do these health benefits of ASMR compare
to the widely reported
health benefits of yoga,
of mindfulness,
of meditation?
And how do these health benefits of ASMR
compare to the therapeutic pros and cons
of medications used
to treat anxiety and insomnia?
And lastly,
will health professionals
someday advocate ASMR
as another tool in the toolbox
to help people manage their stress
and their sleeplessness?
I don’t have the answer
to those questions ...
but I do know one thing.
I know that my vision of a blissful heaven
is Bob Ross greeting me
at the pearly gates
and asking me, “Craig, would
you like a haircut and an eye exam?”
(Laughter)
(Applause)
(Applause and cheers)